hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast building the next generation
of wireless miniaturised microscopes
I am Kristen Perez until of lab roots
and I'll be your moderator for today's
event we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
libraries for more information please
visit Margaret's comm we have a few
important announcements before we begin
this webcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or hearing this presentation please
click on the support button at the top
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the great
green Q&A button lower-left this is an
educational webinar and this offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the see
e button located in the bottom left hand
corner of your web page and follow the
process of obtaining your credits I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Payman Golshani dr. gorshani
obtained his MD and PhD from UC Irvine
and UC Davis where he trained under the
mentorship of dr. Edward G Jones on the
development of cortical elements in us
he then completed his neurology
residency at UCLA and obtained port post
doctoral training with dr. Felix Weiser
and dr. guo King fan where he studied
the role of DNA methylation in
development of cortical circuits he then
became faculty and in collaboration with
dr. Porter Callie oh and dr. Stelios
Smirnov studied the developmental d
synchronous
of internally generated activity in the
cerebral cortex his independent
laboratory now investigates how cortical
micro circuits in the awake behaving
animal encode sensory input and how
disorders such as autism and
developmental epilepsies disrupt
functional cortical connectivity I will
now turn it over to dr. gorshani for his
presentation thank you so much it's
really great to be here I'm really
excited to sort of use this new venue of
presenting our work on these new
generation of wireless miniaturized
microscopes in this whole effort to
open-source miniaturize microscopes
before I start I would like to
acknowledge three collaborators that
have worked with us closely the
collaborators are Alsina silva Baljeet
rock and a jean Markovic who together as
part of a brain initiative grant we have
been been designing and building these
new generation' miniaturized microscopes
and none of this would be possible
without them I also want to acknowledge
three people that have been really
instrumental in building and using the
microscopes the first is Daniel aronia
who was actually our main engineer and
he designed all the miniaturized a new
generation miniaturized microscopes and
and design built and revised these
microscopes until they were usable in
Tristan Schumann and Denise Kai Tristan
is a postdoctoral fellow in my lab and
the nice guys at Wooster postdoctoral
fellow in dr. Alcina Silva's lab and
Tristan and Denise worked together and
tested out these microscopes over and
over and optimized them so that they
were usable and good enough to share
with the community so if if you as we
are interested in really trying to
record the act
any patterns of large numbers of cells
we are we are we have a lot of
limitations to deal with we would like
to be able to record the activity of a
large number of cells we would like to
be there to be single-cell resolution
and we would also like to be able to
record record over a record these same
cells over many many days to weeks to
months however this is not possible with
with most technologies for example with
EEG Zoar local field potentials you can
record across several days two weeks
however you don't have any single-cell
resolution you can you can record with
Tet Rhodes for example but and get
single-cell resolution in freely
behaving animals however you can't
record from these cells you usually over
many days to weeks it's very difficult
to do that plus you would like to be
able to identify the cell types to
record from and so one technique that
has been developed recently by by the
the schnitzer lab and later
commercialized as this these
miniaturized fluorescence microscopes
and we decided to to try to build these
microscopes ourselves and then to
improve on them to make the new
generation of these microscopes and then
to make them available to the community
so so how do you think about these types
of fluorescent microscopes so in essence
you should you can think about the the
microscopes that you have at the EPI
fluorescent microscopes that you may
have in your lab where you use them to
look at fixed issue for example
fluorescent fixed issue in essence these
miniaturize microscopes are exactly that
so you can you you shine light over the
the sample at a particular wavelength
and fluorescence comes back and you can
record this emitted light the technique
has several drawbacks compared to for
example two-photon microscopy
in the sense that you can out-of-focus
light is also image that and there's a
great deal of scattering however with
the new techniques that we've developed
these limitations are far the the
benefits are far outweigh the
limitations in the sense that you can
record in freely behaving animals with
it's really great great temporal
resolution and spatial resolution and
and we can record some identify it
selves and so you can take this emitted
light that comes back and you can look
at the activities of the cells that that
you get and so so imagine your that your
desktop fluorescent microscope this is
an example from an Olympus the x51
microscope and imagine that now you take
each of the parts of this microscope
that are absolutely essential and and
miniaturize it and so for example you
can take you can take the the the the
camera and miniaturize that to a little
cell phone camera and the excitation
light which is generally provided by an
LED or by a mercury lamp can now be
provided by a tiny little LED and so you
take all these components and
miniaturized them to the point that you
can put them on the head of an animal
and that's essentially what we do with
these miniaturized microscopes the
objective is replaced by a green lens
the imaging sensor is replaced by a tiny
CMOS camera and the light source is
replaced by a tiny LED and we have some
control electronics that in the first
version are attached by a wire and all
that fits on top of the mouse's head and
the mouse can walk around with it and
this is essentially what was invented by
this by the schnitzer lab my quinella
Goshen Mark Smith certain colleagues and
published in a few years ago and so as a
first step we decided to see if we could
in essence replicate a lot of what their
microscope delivered and try to make
some
advances so we designed this
head-mounted microscope and we refined
the connectivity to the DAC Hardware by
replacing the the wires that that they
would use by it with a very fine gauge
wire that both delivered power and also
took all the data that was generated by
the camera and brought it to the DAC
Hardware later I will show how this is
replaced in our wireless microscope and
then the DAC Hardware connects to a
computer and all this interfaces with a
behavioral camera that allows you to
watch the watch the the animal and
correlate the activity you see in these
circuits with the behavior of the of the
animal itself and we've also as I will
go into later but try to to make this as
open-source as possible
you've generated a website called mini
scope org and this website users and
developers can interact all the parks
lists and designs and and and circuit
board layouts all the software is all
provided there and people can go there
and develop their own microscopes and
even make improvements to the current
microscopes there's a lot of
interactions and so I'll go into this a
little bit later but I think this is a
critical thing for the development of
this open-source resource and so what
are these microscopes in essence look
like this is the animal on the left you
can see the mouse is carrying this
microscope and the a lens which is you
can see is this you see if I can point
to it this this grin lens here which is
a cylindrical piece of glass that acts
as the focusing mechanism gets implanted
over whatever structure you'd like to
image they had the cells will already be
expressing the genetically encoded
calcium indicator that you're interested
in and later on the animal is brought
back and a base plate isn't
mounted over the head of the animal
which which holds the microscope in
place and this is adjusted with while
the microscope is on the head of the
animal to image the maximal number of
cells and eventually when the animal
needs to be imaged the the microscope
climbs onto this base plate
the cells are imaged then when you're
done the animal doesn't have to go
around with the microscope on his head
and so what what will happen is the
animal will the microscope will come off
and the animal will go back there the
great thing is the the microscope can go
back the next day or the next week and
the same exact group of animals are
imaged and the group of cells are imaged
and and this is all interactive with the
behavioral camera here you can see the
raw images that that we record and the
Delta F over F images that we've been
we've been also recording and you can
see that the signal-to-noise ratios are
quite high and it's almost as good as
two-photon microscopy in this in this
example and so this is a large group of
ca1 they're on several hundred ca1
neurons that we image while this animal
is walking around and so a little bit
more about the microscope so so you can
see a layout of the Micra so the initial
microscope that we designed this is this
is the microscope body that is machined
and the designs are all there and the
mini scope websites this is the grin
lens that we use again I'll point to
things
this is the the grin lens here and the
excitation light and the emitted light
go through it and this focus is the
light and the light will go through the
excitation light is generated by this
LED light this LED which will shine
light that is that is focused on the
sample and the emitted light goes back
up through the emission filter and
through the four Matic lens and
eventually focused onto the CMOS imaging
sensor it's a very simple design
everything is held in place by a set
screw and and this is supplied the
surprisingly simple design leads leads
to very stable imaging over many days to
weeks and here you can see both the
emitted and excitation light the
excitation light provided by the LED
which is reflected by the dichroic
mirror through the grin lens and the
emitted light comes back up through the
dichroic now and pass a chromatic lens
onto the CMOS sensor you can see that
the the resolution of the camera is
quite good and we can get 30 to 60 hertz
imaging which is which is clearly fast
enough for for the existing gcamp
sensors in the future it's possible that
faster sensors even voltage sensors may
come out and this will require us to
update our our cameras to allow us to
image at higher rates and so you can see
here that the path the light takes
through that the several green lenses
this is a to Greenland setup with real a
lens and and another green lens on top
so you can see all this is how we
redesign the microscope this is
example hopefully this will play we're
having some difficulties here but what
you would see here is this animal
running back and forth on this track and
the cells flashing and below you can see
the Delta F over F calcium traces each
each time the cell bursts of active the
cell fires a burst of action potentials
you can see these deflections up and the
slow decay of the calcium transient and
you can see that this is a few of the
cells that are that are displayed but
you can typically record these from
several hundred cells and over several
days more than a thousand cells in one
hippocampal recording and the critical
thing is you'll be able to go back the
same cells day after day week after week
and record from the cells as long as the
the calcium indicator expression is
stable so we have tested in our lab we
have tested these microscopes in a model
of epilepsy we were in in in this
particular experiment we were interested
in epilepsy in a model of temporal lobe
epilepsy because epilepsy is associated
with cognitive dysfunction there are
these these people that have epilepsy
have a great deal of memory difficulties
it's important to understand the
mechanisms that are underlying this and
so in temple of epilepsy there's a lot
of reorganization of circuits a certain
vulnerability AI other other cell
populations try to adjust by sprouting
connections into places they normally
wouldn't and this results in a rewired
hippocampus and ultimately altered
encoding of memories and poor memory
retrieval it's this is a progressive
condition this will get worse and worse
as the epilepsy progresses so we decided
to try to understand how place cell
dynamics are altered in this model and
how more importantly how place so
stability is altered so we created a
model of epilepsy this is the
pilocarpine model where animals have a
prolonged seizure this two-hour seizure
is ended by an injection of diazepam
however after this prolonged seizure
there's a great deal of plasticity and
change in the hippocampus there cell
death and sprouting like I said and
eventually this process leads to
spontaneous seizures so just like the
humans who have spontaneous recurrent
seizures these mice will have
spontaneous return seizures will get
worse and worse as they grow older and
they also have a great deal of memory
difficulties on a lot of cognitive
hippocampal dependent tasks we will
implant the implanted green lenses on
these animals and then water restricted
them and trained them to run on a linear
track and so doing this we will be able
to see place related activity on the
same track over several days and what we
were aiming for us to see how well do
these specific cells encode place
location and how well is this is this
encoding stable over time is it stable
or that is there is there a lot of
remapping in these animals and therefore
instability of their playstyle
representations and so essentially what
we found was that there's there's a
great deal of place related firing in
both control and pilo animals the pilo
animals the epileptic animals show a
little bit of a mild decrease in the
amount of spatial information that
they're firing provides you can sort of
see that year with a little bit of
fuzzing out I'll try to again point to
it the the place fields are a little
broader and less precise compared to the
controls however the the big finding
that we have is that these place fields
are considerably less stable in the
control animal you can see if the place
fields are plotted day after on day
three in the same order that they
on day one you can see that you can even
though there is some remapping you can
clearly see the same representation
shown here by this diagonal which looks
fairly similar to what it looked like in
day one however in the epileptic animal
the same place fields if you plot them
on day three as the animal runs through
the track all the place fields have now
moved and the place field there's a
great deal of instability in this
representation that's not to say that
the animal doesn't have place fields
three days later if you take the same
cells and reorder them now three days
later you can see a fairly good
representation of space it's just not
the same representations the same cells
are now representing the different
locations in space and we have some
quantification which shows that this is
essentially that about 40% of cells
retain their place fields in the control
whereas very few cells are retained in
the epileptic animals shown in red so we
were excited by this and this is a way
this is a great functional biomarker for
us to test various treatments that we
hope to test in the future to see
whether we can improve improve these
place cell representations and make them
more stable and we're in the midst of
doing that I'd like to talk to you a
little bit about our wireless microscope
so we wanted to improve the microscopes
that we currently have so that one thing
is to get rid of the wire because when
animals are tethered by a wire you're
always limited by how far they can
travel also another key thing is that
the wire may tug on the em a little bit
and ingress and and and alter it the way
it behaves on common tasks for example
we've discovered that in social
behaviors that behaviors are not quite
the same when the animal is tethered by
a wire so we wanted to get rid of this
wire so that
you could test the animals in very large
environments very complex environments
including tunnels where these wires
would not work also we have a lot of
collaborators that are interested in
testing these microscopes on animals
that travel very large distances or even
flying animals and so there was a great
deal of motivation to develop these
tools and so we went through several
just to show you the development of
these microscopes we first designed
everything out on a big big circuit
board and then we miniaturized what we
found what we designed to a five point
five grand version with the battery the
the imaging is right now 15 frames per
second but we're trying to speed it back
up and we can get about 10 to 20 minutes
of recording and what we'd like to do is
to to basically miniaturize this further
to below four grams with the battery the
key thing with this microscope is that
there's no wire so what happens to the
data the data is stored on a micro SD
card she may be familiar with there's a
great deal of capacity on these cards
and so the all the data is saved on this
card and at the end of the experiment
that the card is removed and then
uploaded onto a PC the the power which
is so the wire delivers power whereas in
the wireless version the power is
delivered by a lithium a lipo battery
and so that one of the key things is get
these batteries as light as possible but
to give enough capacity so that we can
do a 15 20 minute recording so the key
thing and other key thing is that the
micro SD card is not the limiting
reagent here as far as how long the
recordings can be you can record for
well over an hour if the battery held up
but our batteries sort of run out after
15 to 20 minutes so in an animal that's
larger that can carry much more weight
so you can imagine a rat or a monkey or
or any other animal the battery can be
quite large and so
the this wireless microscope could run
well over an hour without without
problems you could also imagine ways
where this microscope gets triggered to
turn on and turn off and therefore
greatly saving its battery life and be
able to be used over several several
hours so this is an example of what this
looks like this is an animal wearing the
wireless microscope this is a bit
pixelated here but in my version it it
looks much less so it's essentially
identical to what to what we record with
the with the wired microscope there's no
difference and the behavior of the
animals is quite excellent even though
this this particular version is a little
bit more than 4 grams the animals can be
trained to carry it and do the tasks and
so we're quite excited about this
development and hope to release it soon
in our open source version this is our
wiring schematic of the wireless
microscope and you can see the top view
where the micro SD card gets mounted and
the various components that which make
it possible the MCU that runs the whole
circuitry and the CMOS imaging sensor at
the bottom and so like I was saying we'd
like to go below 4 grams with the
battery we'd like to get more than 20
minutes of continuous recordings and 20
frames per second at least and you'd
like to be able to trigger the
microscope to turn on and turn off
through IR communication and we'd like
to also be able to make it so that we
can have a wireless microscope become
wired if we have other needs for that so
we'd like to be able to design that and
you're very close to completing this as
part of the project as part of the brain
initiative grant we also promise to
build several other miniature microscope
one was a and optogenetics capable
microscope and so this is a microscope
where you can not only do calcium
imaging but to be able to deliver
lights to turn on up or turn off cells
using optogenetics what we had in mind
was essentially a version where there's
instead of one LED there's two LEDs one
blue LED to excite channelrhodopsin and
another LED to excite this other calcium
indicator junior camp 1a where the where
the the emissions the excitations of the
two don't overlap and so we'd like to be
able to image the junior camp 1a at the
same time as we excite channelrhodopsin
and be able to see how this excitation
of whatever cells are expressing
channelrhodopsin alters the activity of
these cells so this is something we're
currently designing and building we know
that the junior camp 1a works fine sorry
looks look doesn't work anyways and we
know that the junior chem 1a works well
almost as well as the G camps you'd also
like to develop a two-channel imaging
we've had some trouble because of
chromatic aberration through the grin
lenses so the red and green cells that
we image haven't exactly lined up in the
z axis we have many different solutions
that we're trying in order to develop
these two channel microscopes so that
you can image both a red and a green
channel together so finally a little bit
more about our our mini scope dot org
website this is slide is a little bit
old we have over 1500 you user accounts
we have hundreds of visits to our wiki
site every week there's over 150 labs
that are building the microscopes we
know because of we have access to who is
who is ordering the various parts and so
that's our estimate at about 150 laps or
building the microscopes and we hear
from them quite frequently I've heard
from a lot of people who have been able
to finally secure an an eye
experience that they've been trying to
get for a while by incorporating this
new technology and it's critical that
you know we don't make any money off
these microscopes they're quite
inexpensive to build about less than a
thousand dollars for our standard
versions there's active discussion
boards where people that are building
the microscopes discuss issues that they
may have or suggestions for improvements
we've also had several workshops where
usually twenty to thirty people come to
each workshop one of the workshops is
very large right before the Society for
Neuroscience meetings as several hundred
people attended that but in these
workshops people learn how to assemble
the microscopes how to implant them the
tricks for the surgeries all this stuff
is actually also on the mini scope dot
or website and everything that you need
to basically pick up these microscopes
and start using them is there and so we
don't a lot of people are using them and
we never actually even hear about it
that the slide shows all the logins to
our website from all different parts of
the world and people actually have
attended our workshops from Israel and
Korea and Germany and a lot of other
other countries so we're we're very
happy that sort of the obstacles to the
use of these technologies are are are
being have been removed and and that
even I've even heard of people that are
instituting these microscopes that in
undergraduate classes or even in high
schools they're building these
microscopes and using them not maybe
implanted on animals but just as as a
sort of desktop fluorescent microscopes
for projects for their students and and
so I am really a big believer in really
removing all the barriers such that all
it takes is someone who has a really
good idea and they could build the
microscopes with very little money and
to be able to use it and gather data and
then sort of build off their idea these
are
pictures of several of our workshops and
you can see that a lot of people are
interested in and we will have our final
workshop in in April in mid-april and
before I end I would I already thanked
alsina Silva and about sheetrock and de
Jonge Markovic but I also wanted to
thank other people that have helped
Daniel again who designed the
microscopes Tristan Schumann and Denis
Chi who who tested and optimized the
microscopes with revisions Katie McGuire
Chris Lee from my lab sighs oof rum
valchek Doc's lab Michael yartsa
actually at UC Berkeley who has been
openly working with us to improve the
microscopes for wireless capability
Sotiris Mossman Eva Santa Clair who have
been designing a combo scope that that
includes both electrophysiology and
imaging that I didn't talk about I also
wanted to acknowledge there you'll one
brain initiative grant that funded all
this work also support from our dean's
office and our departments of Neurology
neurobiology and physiology
thank you so much
thank you for that informative
presentation dr. gorshani before we get
started on the question-and-answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found on clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can and our first question from our
audience today is do you think these
microscopes could be used in animals
other than mice out of interest in
people that are working with other
models they like I said there's interest
in people that are studying
communication and navigation in bats
also I know of people studying marmosets
that are trying to implant these
microscopes and use them there is a big
interest from the primate community to
implant not just one but multiple
microscopes to do calcium imaging so
there is there is a very big interest a
lot of tools need to be optimized for
these model systems in in rats we've had
some difficulty for example imaging
hippocampus whereas in my suite we've
had no difficulties but rats because the
the Orient is thicker it's been harder
to get the cell bodies in focus and ca1
so I give that as an example of the
difficulties that you can have in
imaging different structures and
different animals but I think they're
also mountable all these problems can be
surrounded and and just take some trial
and error
okay we have time for one more question
what are the downsides of using these
microscopes versus two-photon microscopy
about the upsides the upsides of the
microscopes so there's a lot of
advantages one is that the animal is
freely behaving so it's not head risk
frame there's a lot of behaviors that
are very difficult to do and head
constrained animals and that's something
that we've been trying to to get over
but having a having a microscope that
just fits on the animal's head and gets
rid of the head restraints is it's a
really an amazing thing for all those
behaviors where head restraint doesn't
make sense so that's that's the positive
then the negatives are compared to two
photon microscopy are the you may not
have the the Z resolution to be able to
perfectly distinguish several cells that
may be on top of each other such that if
they became active at the same time you
couldn't really distinguish them and so
there is there is some some worry that
you may end up with multi unit
recordings at rare time points when you
in fact wanted to record only from a
single unit and so this problem is much
less of a problem with two-photon
microscopy because because because the
ability to optically section through
tissue is much much much better with two
photons that being said there are labs
that are trying to build to float on
microscopes already some have been built
it seemed quite excellent and so this
seems to be a direction where you may
want to go there may be some downsides
for example you'd be more sensitive to
the Z motion using it to float on
because the cell could come in and out
of focus more rapidly than than an FP
fluorescent microscope so so I think
there are there's certainly some
advantages and disadvantages
two thoughts on microscopy the
two-photon I think you can image smaller
structures and Hritik spines axonal
bouton that you may not be able to with
their big fluorescent microscope but all
these may change as you as we go on and
develop this technology thanks dr.
gorshani thank you again for your
presentation do you have any final
comments say that I'm very excited to be
I'm very excited to be developing this
technology with all our collaborators
and I'm excited that that people will
have access to this technology and to be
able to incorporate it into their into
their labs at very low cost and that's
always been our goal is to share as
quickly as possible once the equipment
is tested to share our technology so
that it can it can be used by anyone who
wants so I'm quite excited about that
thank you thank you today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2017 you won't receive
an email from lab roots alerting you
when this webcast will be available for
replay we invite you to forward that
announcement to your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event see you
next time goodbye